Jack Van Horn: All right, shall we begin?
Good morning, everyone.
This is Jack Van Horn from
the BD2K training coordinating
center, based at the University
of Southern California.
And I'd like to welcome you
all to our next installment
of our BD2K Guide to the
Fundamentals of Data Science
seminar series.
This morning, we're
absolutely delighted to have
Pascale Gaudet from the Swiss
Institute of Bioinformatics,
who will be lecturing on data
curation and version control.
Dr. Gaudet has been working
as a biocurator since 2003--
first with the model organism
database, dicta base,
at Northwestern University
in Chicago, during which time
she became heavily involved
in the gene ontology project.
Since October of 2010,
Dr. Gaudet has been
the scientific manager
of the neXtProt
database at the Swiss
Institute of Bioinformatics,
which is based in Switzerland.
She is one of the founding
members of the International
Society for Biocurators, and
has served as its chairperson
from 2009 to 2013.
This morning, she
is going to be,
again, talking about data
curation and version control.
And she will attempt to
explain what a biocurator is--
what biocuration
is-- and what is
the process by which the
lifecycle of scientific data
goes through, and
discuss relevant issues.
For all of you
who are listening,
I encourage you to chat in
using the little chat box
feature, of your questions,
and I will act to curate them
myself and ask them
on your behalf.
Without further ado,
Dr. Gaudet, welcome,
and thank you very much.
Pascale Gaudet: Thank you for that
introduction, and thank you
for inviting me to
give this lecture.
I'm really-- can you
see my screen OK?
Jack Van Horn: Yes, we can.
Pascale Gaudet: OK, so just to say
it's a big honor for me
to be part of this course.
And I'm very pleased
of the recognition
by BD2K of the importance of
biocuration in data science,
and in biomedical research.
So this is to summarize
what Jack just
said about me- so I'm the
scientific manager of neXtProt
at the Swiss Institute
of Bioinformatics.
I'm also still
currently a manager
on the gene ontology
project, specifically
on the phylogenetic
annotation approach project.
And here I copied what some
other previous presenters did,
and I gave the people my
email, and my Twitter account,
in case you want to
continue discussing
what I'm going to be talking
about today, after this talk.
So databases right now are
a cornerstone for research.
Curated databases are a
tool that most [AUDIO OUT]
right now, on a day [AUDIO OUT].
And many users
spend several hours
per week on various databases.
When I was at
DictyBase, we surveyed
our users and many
people estimated
that they were spending probably
one day a week, over all,
on various resources.
However, database
creation and maintenance
is an obscure process
to most users.
Sorry-- I just need
to get rid of this.
Yes, so database
creation and maintenance
is an obscure process
to most users.
And this is what I want to
talk about to you today.
So I am sure everybody
here has interacted
with many of these different
types of resources,
but this is to
give you an idea--
or to remind you-- of the
scope of curated resources
in the life sciences.
So there is databases that
talk about protein functions,
genomes, chemicals, clinical
trials, interactions
with ligands, with
drugs, with proteins.
There's a large
number of databases.
In fact, the main reference, in
terms of biological databases,
is the yearly nucleic
acids research
database, which, in 2016, listed
1,665 different databases.
And there's the link here
for the list of databases
that are compiled by
Michael Galperin, who's
the editor for the Nucleic
Acids Research Database Issue.
I want to point out that this
is not an exhaustive list of all
the databases that exist.
The NAR database issue
selects resources
that are deemed of
high quality, that
are not redundant with
other existing resources.
So in other words, if
you want to propose
a repackaging of
other databases,
it's usually not
going to make it
in the collection of databases.
And also, they select
resources that are maintained.
So just to say, there
is a large number
of what we call niche
databases, usually created
for specific projects, but
that are not maintained once,
for example, the students
or post-doc moves
onto a different project.
So these are excluded from the
Nucleic Acids Research Database
Issue.
And even within this
collection, there's
still a small number that
goes obsolete every year.
And so just as a
point to mention,
this year there
were 23 resources
that were removed,
because they didn't
seem to be maintained anymore.
So today, I'm going to talk
about what is biocuration?
Why do biocuration?
And how do we do biocuration?
So to give a definition
of biocuration,
we can say that it's the
analysis, interpretation,
and integration of biological
information into data
repositories.
So it's, in part, data
capture, but that's
really just one aspect.
To do biocuration, you need
to understand the data,
and you need to
analyze it, and you
need to distill what the
researchers are trying
to show in order to translate
this into a language
that a computer will
be able to understand.
And-- this is a
little subtlety--
without falling into the trap
of over interpreting data
when, for example, interesting
new theories are discussed
in papers, but there's not
the exact supporting evidence
that one needs to
really say that this is
an observation that
has been shown,
whereas  this is a
conclusion that we might
want to test in the future.
So this data is integrated
into some structure form--
usually it's a database, but
it doesn't really have to be.
This is very technical.
I'm not going to focus
on the technical aspects.
And so really, biocuration
encompasses a wide range
of activities.
So this definition
may not include
all the different
activities, but to give you
an idea of some of
the typical tasks
that a biocurator
might do-- it's
to conceptualize [AUDIO OUT]
certain types of data,
to create databases,
to evaluate data,
insert it in the database,
and also, if possible,
link it so that it makes
sense biologically.
And obviously store it.
So why do biocuration?
Right now, as we
know, modern research
generates huge
quantities of data.
And while each data set is
very rich-- or each data point,
even-- is very rich on its own.
Where it becomes
powerful and interesting
is when we can [AUDIO OUT]
the different data
from different groups from
different types of experiments,
and so on.
And so one aim of biocuration
and curated databases
is to be able to connect
and query all the knowledge
that we have generated as
a scientific community.
I mean, I think this is
anyways a common goal
of the entire
scientific community.
So why biocuration?
Is also because papers,
in the traditional form,
are not easily amenable
to computational analysis.
So the data that is there,
the knowledge that is there,
is very difficult to extract.
So it used to be that when there
was a little less literature
accumulated, people
could be expert and have
read everything in their field.
But more and more, this is
becoming almost impossible.
Another thing is that biological
data is very heterogeneous.
So there's many
different techniques
that ask similar questions.
New techniques are
constantly being developed.
So one of the challenges
is also [AUDIO OUT] systems
where all this data can be a
little bit more interoperable.
And so this is not exactly
built into how people currently
do experiments.
So right now, we're at
a stage where the data
and the knowledge generated
by experiments cannot be
immediately consumed for
other types of analyses.
So right now, the process
is to convert this
into a form that
can be computed.
So the idea with
biocuration is that if we
have data that is
correctly captured, then
we can facilitate retrieval,
extraction, indexation,
and make the data, as
a whole, more valuable.
So what we're hoping for, that
a curated knowledge database
will provide, is
easy access to data.
Data that is-- so I'm
repeating this a little bit,
but this is really
very important
in terms of why we're doing
[AUDIO OUT] status [AUDIO OUT]
Also [AUDIO OUT] and
ideally the [AUDIO OUT]
The other thing is it
enables [AUDIO OUT].
And just a point on the
current [AUDIO OUT], sometimes
if you [AUDIO OUT],
and you haven't
read other articles that have
been published afterwards,
you don't know if what was
demonstrated in that article
is still the best [AUDIO OUT]
you're looking at.
So ideally, we would
have a way-- you know,
databases aim to provide the
current state of knowledge.
So data has been shown to
be incorrect or inaccurate
should be removed, or corrected.
OK, so how do we do biocuration?
There is really [AUDIO OUT].
The first one is manual,
and the other one
is automated, or assisted
with text mining.
I'm going to describe
both approaches.
But first, I'm going to
focus on the manual approach.
So some of the
[AUDIO OUT] for-- oh yeah,
so I just want to say
that for today's talk,
I give some examples
of literature curation.
Obviously [AUDIO OUT]
there's many types
of data that are curated.
There is many type of databases,
like I mentioned earlier.
So for the examples
today, I'm going
to focus on literature
curation, just for simplicity.
Unfortunately, there
is no time to go over
all the different types of
curation that can be done.
But one that comes
to mind, really
very important
thing that I won't
be talking about this-- genome
annotation, gene models,
sequence features, and so on.
So here is an overview
of what a curator does,
as specific steps,
when annotating
a paper from the literature.
So first, you need what I
call bio-entities [AUDIO OUT]
that are in the paper.
Because usually what
people want to do
is to connect [AUDIO OUT]
modification or a phenotype.
So you need to know what gene
is being described in the paper.
[AUDIO OUT] seem trivial
to people doing research
and writing papers,
but when you're
on the other end-- reading
papers and trying to extract
this information-- in fact, it's
an extremely challenging task.
Of course, there is
trivial [AUDIO OUT].
For example, when a gene name
is the synonym of another gene--
so sometimes you
need to [AUDIO OUT]
a paper is talking about.
Issues of [AUDIO OUT]
that can be [AUDIO OUT]
describe variance, or even post
translational modification.
[AUDIO OUT] And you
know [AUDIO OUT]
on the current
reference sequence
is different from the one that
was presented in the paper--
it's also to be resolved.
And also, [AUDIO OUT] it can be
difficult to find the species
that is described in a paper.
There's several cases
that we have encountered
where a paper talks
about a human process,
but somehow when you
read in very detail,
the materials and methods-- or
sometimes, even it has happened
that we had to do a
blast, and then we
realized that, in fact, it
was a mouse protein being
expressed in a human cell.
OK, so we just always
want to make sure
that whatever information
is extracted from the paper
is linked to the correct
biological entity.
So this is the first
thing-- is to just extract
which gene the paper, or genes
the paper is talking about.
Also, obviously,
you want to extract
whatever real
information knowledge is
published in the paper.
So for example, they show
a molecular function,
or they show a pathway
in which the gene is
involved in-- a
[? phosphorylation ?]
site, a phenotype, and so on.
And synthesize the
information to represent,
like I said, the current
state of knowledge.
So it also happens
that [AUDIO OUT]
occurs at the level of
detail presentation.
Here are some examples of
bio-entity recognition issues.
So maybe some of you
are familiar with APC,
which represents either a
protein involved in a colon
cancer, or the
anaphase-promoting complex.
So people familiar with that
literature would be immediately
know that these are
different kinds of papers.
But it is not trivial for
everybody to recognize.
There's also, here I put
some drosophila genes,
but it's not that it's
the only case where
there's genes that
are named with words
that are real English words.
And so, obviously,
this can also cause
a false negative
problems-- you're
looking for the
literature for that gene,
and you find a lot of papers
that talk about white.
But it's very difficult to
find the papers that talk
about the gene, white.
And I mentioned in
the previous slide,
the sequence size of
[? foreign ?] species issues.
But this something
that curators spend
a long time trying to sort
out, when annotating a paper.
So to discuss a little bit the
second step of the biocuration
task [AUDIO OUT] I'm going to
give you an example of work
that we've done in my group.
So we've curated the
functional impact
of variations in
the human genome
for a number of cancer variants.
And so we were
interested in really
capturing the molecular
mechanism of these variants.
So we can [AUDIO OUT]
cellular processes,
and molecular
[AUDIO OUT] binding,
changes in [AUDIO OUT] or in
sub-cellular localization.
And this is the overview
of the MLH1.
I'm sure many of you have
seen these types of databases
where you can go and
browse some information.
[AUDIO OUT] Show you the
phenotypes of the gene, MLH1,
involved in colo-rectal cancer.
And at the first level, we
show the different phenotypes
that are tested for this gene.
So there is-- I cannot
get my mouse to work here,
but we have divided
them by groups.
So the molecular
function-- [AUDIO OUT]
[? ATPA's ?] activity.
There is also impact
on biological process--
so the [AUDIO OUT]
is not [AUDIO OUT].
It's localization,
which is nuclear,
and impacts on some important
binary interactions.
And you can go in and
search for any gene that
has a defect in a specific
phenotype you're interested in.
So for example, you can look at
the list of variants that have
defects and mismatch repair.
And so here, there's four
different variants listed.
So this is a
partial [AUDIO OUT],
100 different variants
for this gene,
with problems and
mismatch repair.
And so we also show all
the evidence for the data
that we're capturing.
So this is, I think,
very important in terms
of trusting the data.
Anybody who downloads
this list can then
go back to the
original literature,
and decide if you agree
with the information which
is presented there.
So this was the end
result. So going back
on how we actually
extract the information--
so this is one of the articles
that we used to annotate MLH1.
And so one of the challenges--
[AUDIO OUT] is dispersed.
In this case, there's
information dispersed
within the same table,
but sometimes it's
even more widespread
in the paper.
So we have the gene name,
MLH1, [INAUDIBLE] of the title
of the table, a
list of mutations,
and of [AUDIO OUT] in the table.
We also have the phenotypes
in which we're interested in,
that I highlighted in yellow.
So the MSI status-- it stands
for microsatellite instability
status.
So this is something
that [AUDIO OUT] tumors,
and it measures
essentially whether or not
the mismatch repair system
is functional or not.
And in this case it's given a
qualitative value-- high, low,
or not tested.
And then the other column we
were interested in capturing,
like I mentioned, is
the protein stability.
And so in this case, it's
tested by immunocytochemistry.
So we know this, because
we know that in this case,
immunocytochemistry
measures the level
of the protein in the cell.
But obviously, you can
do immunocytochemistry
to measure many other things,
just a localization, and so on.
Also, there is, in
this table, a number
of variants that are not
original from this paper--
[? data. ?] So for
some reason, they
thought these were interesting,
and the authors added them
in their analysis.
But the data wasn't [AUDIO OUT].
And so in these
cases, we [AUDIO OUT]
just cited, because
we [AUDIO OUT].
We only capture each
experiment only once.
If it's cited in a
secondary publication,
we don't capture it.
Because otherwise, it would
give artificial weight
to the assertion, because it's
been found X number of times.
So I think it's very important
that [AUDIO OUT] any time
something has been shown,
that that data doesn't
get duplicated in the
annotation process.
This is a similar data,
a different paper.
So in this case,
they also [AUDIO OUT]
histochemistry, as
you see on the left.
And they tested in what
they call step 2-- MMR
assay-- which is also
testing mismatch repair.
It's very similar
data, it's just
presented in a
very different way.
So the legend says
that the black cells
represent pathogenic or
deficient [AUDIO OUT].
White cells are non-pathogenic.
The diagonal line means
that it hasn't been tested,
and the gray cells mean that
there is conflicting data.
So this is something that,
manually, we can understand,
but that automatic
annotation systems,
I don't know of any system that
can extract the information
from such a table.
Now this paper [AUDIO OUT]
you find quite frequently
in research papers,
is a small case f
next to the variant
PK 618 alanine.
So in the legend, it
says that these families
have additional mutations.
So in this case, there's two
mutations in the same gene.
And so, of course,
[AUDIO OUT] footnote
may be very important in
terms of the explanation
of the phenotype.
So in this case, we're
looking at a double mutant,
but in the table it's
presented as a single mutant.
So again, this is some
of the very detailed work
that our team, and
many other teams,
does to make sure
that we extract
all the information accurately.
Now, I mentioned that there's
a microsatellite instability,
and the second paper
had MMR-- which
is a mismatch repair assay.
There's different
types of experiments
that test the same thing, in
this mismatch repair field.
So in this case, I listed
four different experiments--
microsatellite instability,
in vitro mismatch repair
assay, mutator phenotype
assay, [AUDIO OUT].
These assays all reflect
defective mismatch repair
pathway.
So we believe that
it's very important
that these be captured
in the same manner,
[? or ?] that there is
four different [AUDIO OUT].
To explain a little bit
more about the work on gene
ontology, I think
many of you must
be familiar with gene ontology--
it's one of the most widely
used bioinformatics resource.
It's a shared language
for a [? gene notation ?]
of molecular
[AUDIO OUT] functions
and biological process
and cellular components
across different organisms.
And it covers three different
domains, like I just said--
functional, process, component.
And [AUDIO OUT]
developed this as exactly
to be able to standardize the
description of gene function.
Like I just said, biocurators
link gene, or gene products,
or modified proteins and so on--
two times of the gene ontology,
or various ontologies,
in order for the data
to be organized in
a consistent way
and for a user to be
able to consume it
in a way that is [AUDIO OUT].
So in terms of the MLH1
protein, for example,
that I was mentioning,
its function
is to bind another complex.
It's involved in
mismatch repair,
and it's localized
to the nucleus.
OK, and it has a number of
other more subtle and gene
ontology functions
annotations-- [AUDIO OUT]
gene ontology annotations
to function or process
a component.
But these are the
most central ones.
So I suppose that you might be
familiar with other biomedical
ontologies.
There is, right now, biomedical
ontologies in most areas.
So to describe anatomies,
chemicals, diseases,
[AUDIO OUT] experiments-- so the
mass spectrometry community has
an ontology that describes the
different techniques that they
use.
There's also--
yeah, [? indigo ?]
can describe protein function,
and sub cellular component.
Can describe phenotypes, can
describe proteins, and protein
families, sequence, and so on.
So this is really one way to
represent the data, that also
has been proven [AUDIO OUT]
research community,
if we just look at how much
the gene ontology is being used
in bioinformatics applications.
So one [AUDIO OUT] comment
that we often get about
by manual biocuration is
that it [AUDIO OUT] it's
[AUDIO OUT] long and it
doesn't scale easily.
Although it's very
accurate, we need
to develop ways to make
manual annotation [AUDIO OUT].
So I'm going to give you one
example in that direction.
In the gene ontology
consortium, we
have developed a tool called
PAINT-- phylogenetic-based
annotation inference.
And what you do is we make
gene ontology annotations
[AUDIO OUT] relations.
So I'm just going to
spend a couple of slides
describing this.
Here what we have on the
left is a gene family
for MSH2, which is another
member of the mismatch repair
complex.
So there's proteins-- this is
conserved from human to E coli.
And so the sequences in green
are experiments [AUDIO OUT]
by other groups.
And [? again, ?]
do, using this is we
look at the relationships
of all these genes,
and then we can decide where
a function, first of all.
And then we, what we
call, propagate or infer
that function to a node--
a phylogenetic ancestor
that we choose.
And [AUDIO OUT]
is the second step
of the annotation, where
from this ancestor,
the annotations are propagated
to all the ones and blue,
the ones that didn't
have any annotations.
So the workflow is to look at
the experimental annotations
shown here in blue.
And so essentially
the process is
we look for the most
recent common ancestor,
and then we decide if we want
to annotate to that [AUDIO OUT],
or if we think that
it should be annotated
to a more recent ancestor,
or a more ancient ancestor.
And so then from
[AUDIO OUT] these decisions
include, for example, sequence
conservation, active site
presence or absence, and
a number of other things.
And so I don't know if you can
see this alignment, probably,
but we can also annotate
loss of function.
So it happens in big
multi-gene families
that certain functions are lost.
In this case, it's because
an active site is lost.
So this cysteine
[AUDIO OUT] PGM5,
but in the PGM1 [INAUDIBLE],
this cysteine is mutated
to [? NSR ?] gene.
And therefore their
function is low
after this duplicate event
indicated in the green circle.
And so using this,
[AUDIO OUT] to say that there
has been a loss of function.
And so this is to
give you some idea
of how much more we
can do, using this more
efficient curation system.
So as of last year, we had 2,500
different families curated--
so the families are based
on patho [? DB. ?] Right now
there's a [AUDIO OUT] families
in the whole [? patho DB ?]
set, so we've done
about a quarter.
And within those
2,500 families, there
has been over 5,000 human
genes annotated, and 20,000
new human gene annotations.
And if you look at,
also, all the organisms,
we have nearly 1 million
annotations with this system.
This scales quite
well in the sense
that one curator can do
about 1,000 families a year.
Which, if you take the average,
it corresponds more or less
to 100,000 genes.
So the only drawback
is that, of course,
we still need the primary
annotations in order
to be able to do this.
But the nice thing is,
it annotates multiple new
[AUDIO OUT] no annotations.
So now I'm going to
switch gears a little bit,
to talk about
automated curation.
So the manual curation is
very nice, but like I said,
it's time consuming.
And there's a lot of hope
that some automated systems
could help us do curation
more effectively.
So the task that
automated curation tools
that I'm aware of do, include
document retrieval, document
prioritization, what
they call-- so let's
see if you're interested
in a specific gene,
a specific disease,
it can retrieve
documents that are relevant
to that gene disease process.
These tools [AUDIO OUT]
these document,
[AUDIO OUT] which ones
are more likely to be
more interesting to you.
Gene normalization
task is to try
to identify which gene the
paper is talking about.
So this task, as far as I know--
maybe there's been more recent
developments where
this is [AUDIO OUT]--
as I explained
earlier in my talk,
even manually we
have a lot of issues.
So the automatic systems who are
not usually performing really
well in this task.
And finally, another task
is concept identification.
So which gene is mentioned
in the paper, or [AUDIO OUT]
mentioned in the paper?
And so on.
So these are all tasks that
we can ask automated systems
to help us with.
One very popular tool in
the biocuration community,
for automatic annotation,
is called Textpresso.
It's developed by the
group [AUDIO OUT},
who also is [? PI ?] of
the one base database.
And so it was first
implemented in one base,
but it's now in more and
more frequently being
implemented in other
[AUDIO OUT] in DictyBase,
and the Arabidopsis
thaliana resource.
So with Texpresso
can do is, if it's
given on the left,
a number of PDFs
of relevant literature, gene
product names and synonyms
that it can use a search base.
And while for [INAUDIBLE] and
plant [? cellular ?] component
[? times. ?] So essentially
you have your literature,
and your list of genes that
you're interested in-- what
Textpresso does is it
converts the PDF to text,
it tries to identify the
gene, gene product names.
It marks up the text of
the paper, it indexes it.
And then it presents it to the
curator in a way [INAUDIBLE].
I'm just going to
show you-- this
is from the 2012 papers
that describe implementation
of Texpresso in DictyBase
and in [AUDIO OUT].
And so this is the
curation interface.
So at the top is title and
abstract of the of the paper.
And then at the bottom, you
see the gene protein name
that the system extracted.
The gene ontology cellular
component term, nuclear,
that it found in
this [AUDIO OUT].
Then you can also select more
specific or less specific
term [AUDIO OUT].
And then the curator just sees
this pre-processed annotation,
and can hit Make the Annotation,
or Don't Make the Annotation,
and this goes directly
in the database.
Now, in automatic annotation,
the gold standard measures
are precisions and
recall
are the fraction of the
documents retrieved that are
relevant to your query.
So how much of
your [INAUDIBLE]
did you really find?
And the precision
is the fraction
of the documents
that are retrieved,
and that are relevant.
Because the system obviously
can also give you some false
positives.
So their recall is-- it
measures, more or less,
the false negatives [AUDIO OUT]
or the false positives.
And so this is, again,
from the paper-- so
for DictyBase and TAIR, the
recall was maximum [AUDIO OUT].
So there's still 50%
of the literature
that the curators needed to go
back to and annotate manually.
And the precision was
between 60% and 75%.
So sometimes there were a
number of false positives, too.
But despite that, here
I call this [AUDIO OUT]
cost reduction.
That's not how they phrased it
in the paper, but in the paper
they say, a 2.5 fold increase
in curation efficiency.
So it's still pretty good--
you can annotate more than two
times the number of papers that
you would without the system.
The cons here, I would say
that usually these things don't
take into [AUDIO OUT]
development [AUDIO OUT]
of the infrastructure
that you need [AUDIO OUT].
And also, there's
[AUDIO OUT] large projects
in this area that [AUDIO OUT]
to [AUDIO OUT] a real life
setting.
So right now, it's
still pretty embryonic,
and there's lots of
research going on.
But in [AUDIO OUT] able
to use automated methods,
for biocuration, there is a lot
of tasks that cannot be done.
So we talked about
what, why, how--
and now I would like to talk
about who does biocuration.
So as Jack mentioned, before
[AUDIO OUT] biocuration
is done by a professional
biocurator, such as me.
So we surveyed the
biocurators back in 2012,
and there's a paper that
described who are these people,
and where they come from, and
why they became interested
in this area.
But just to say that,
most people have
a lot of experience--
most are PhDs,
most have a lot of experience
as bench scientists, so most
[AUDIO OUT] and also post-docs.
Some people have done
some programming,
and usually people stay in
biocuration for a long time.
So people are
experienced researchers,
and experienced curators.
Also it was mentioned
that the biocurators have
a professional society,
called the International
Society for Biocuration-- and
[AUDIO OUT] different members
that represents about 150
different institutions.
There is annual
international meetings
that are very interesting
in terms of giving people
new ideas, and new ways to do
things, and to collaborate.
So I think these are really,
really good for the community.
And it's amazing that
next year is already
going to be the 10th annual
meeting of the International
Society for Biocuration.
So this is a bit
restating what I
said at the beginning in
terms of the importance
of curated resources, but
from the point of view
of the biocurators, themselves.
So what you would
like to have is
to have compatible
infrastructure
for data deposition,
exchange, and analysis.
So it's important that we have
common controlled vocabularies,
compatible tools, compatible
identifiers, data formats,
[AUDIO OUT] systems, and so on.
At the same time, it's
[AUDIO OUT] balance, stability,
and innovation.
We don't want to be in a
situation where [AUDIO OUT] are
so rigid that people cannot
start doing new types
of experiments.
So this is also
very challenging,
to be that compatible
and move forward
at the same time.
We would like for the
resources that we're
developing to be sustainable.
And [AUDIO OUT] to get
researchers involved.
So that's one aspect
of the one group
of people who do biocuration.
There's other
[AUDIO OUT] approach
has been used [AUDIO OUT].
So crowdsourcing can be divided
into three different aspects.
One is [AUDIO OUT] scientists to
contribute to your [AUDIO OUT].
There's a wikigenes-- I know
back seven, 10 years ago,
most of the
[? multi-organisms ?] databases
had submitted their wiki to
try to get researchers to add
their own data if they wanted.
Rfam is one of the best
example of a very [AUDIO OUT].
The second approach
in crowdsourcing
is [AUDIO OUT] that people
might know as [AUDIO OUT] Amazon
perks.
So you can go to Amazon
and propose-- I mean,
that's one [AUDIO OUT], but
you propose a very small task,
and people are paid a
small amount to do one unit
[INAUDIBLE] to identify
variance in an abstract.
So just to tell you, is this
string of text a variant,
yes or no?
[AUDIO OUT] paper that Jeanette
Harshman published about this.
It was quite successful
for that small task.
But then, of course, if you want
to do more complicated tasks,
then you need to start
making bigger payments.
And you also
[AUDIO OUT] where you
control for the contributors,
their expertise,
how many false positives
they give you, and so on.
Like, what's the
quality of their work.
There is also an
interesting idea
in developing games that
could help somehow integrate
data in a more structured way.
So there's-- well, Foldit is not
exactly going into databases,
but for protein predictions,
was the most successful game
in biology, where people--
biologists and other people--
could try to find the best
structure for a protein whose
structure was not known.
There's also Cancer
Research UK, who
developed a few games and--
well, other groups, [INAUDIBLE]
among other people--
I don't know why
I forgot to put his name there.
So there's a few
ideas of getting
people involved in a fun way.
But it hasn't been
picked up-- it's
not like everybody's playing
these bioinformatics game
while they're waiting for
the bus, or something.
At least not as far as I know.
So the pros of
crowdsourcing are a lot
of potential contributors.
There is a significant
cost to developing
all this infrastructure--
many of them,
if they're not used
very much, well, it
becomes money that was
invested for not much return.
And mostly, at least the
reports I have looked at,
describe pretty low
rates of participation.
So that's too bad,
really, because it
would be a really great.
[? A ?] group which is very
important for biocuration
as a whole, is researcher.
Many research projects
involve some curation.
And that data has not always
contributed back to databases--
or often it's not.
There are some journals
that encourage researchers
to provide data in formats
that can be directly inserted
in databases.
So for example, gen
ontology annotations,
a few journals
request that.
But, clearly, the incentives
are not yet there for people
to really provide a lot of data.
Researchers have a lot
of other [AUDIO OUT].
There is not much
recognition for having
provided your data or not.
So we really need
to work on providing
better incentives
for researchers
to curate their own data.
And one obvious way
that I can think
is-- and that's
discussed a lot lately,
it's not my idea--
is to give some
either via your [? arch ID ?]
or some other mechanism,
that curated data would
receive some citable unit.
So the last little
bit of the talk,
I'm going to discuss
versioning issues.
So because all these
curated databases
are available out there, there's
more and more experiments
that rely on these resources
for data analysis--
especially in the
high throughput area.
However, most papers that I read
that do bioinformatics analysis
do not provide enough data to
reproduce their experiment,
their data analysts experiment.
So that's one issue.
This is [AUDIO OUT]
likely different issue
is, I mentioned that
biocurated resources want
to be up to date, with respect
to their current knowledge.
So this is an example
of a case where
we have a protein that
is a [? diomer. ?]
And when the A subunit
is down to the B subunit,
the A subunit inhibit the
activity of the B [AUDIO OUT].
Now, there is a
protease that comes in,
and that degrades the A
subunit, and the B subunit
becomes active.
So this is not a very
complicated mechanism
of regulation.
So the A subunit is
involved in regulation.
The B subunit-- has
it's a nuclease,
it has the
deoxyribonuclease activity.
Now, the reason
why I'm saying this
is that, we didn't know
that it was a complex.
We had only identified
the A subunit.
And they thought that the
A subunit had the activity.
So when you read the
[INAUDIBLE] literature,
then you realize
that the resolution
that the first assays
were not good enough,
and their results were--
I guess you can say wrong,
but it was just misleading.
That the way they
did the experiment,
they didn't have the resolution
to determine whether that there
were two subunits there.
So the idea is that,
to remove this--
to remove the incorrect
annotation, to make sure
that the knowledge
is kept up to date.
And where I want
to go with this is
this is just an example--
like a very specific example--
but I want to show you
that annotations evolved.
Annotation evolved
quite a bit, in fact.
So here there is a tool
developed by [? Paltov ?]
[? Lidis, ?] at the University
of British Columbia,
where you can query either a
gene, or a gene ontology term,
and see how it
changes over time.
And in this case, I just picked
a protein kinase activity,
and we see for different
species, the number
of annotations over time,
since 2002-- [AUDIO OUT]
of annotations anyways, only
human-annotated protein kinase
activity.
But it's not, as one might
expect, a linear increase.
There's also time where there
is a big drop, or big increase.
And so that means
that depending on when
you do your bioinformatics
experiment using this data,
your results can change
quite dramatically.
And to illustrate
this, there was a paper
published just a
few [AUDIO OUT],
that shows the impact of
outdated gene annotation
on pathway enrichment analysis.
So for high
throughput experiment,
pathway enrichment analysis
is really something
that people almost always
present in the paper.
And what they've
shown here is they
looked at a number of
different articles--
so they took annotations
from 2010 and [AUDIO OUT] 16,
and checked from these
different data sets, which
terms were most enriched.
And so the purple dots are
2016, and blue dots are 2000--
I'm sorry, yellow are
2010, and blue dots
are the ones that are
found in [? both. ?]
So you see that there is
a number of [AUDIO OUT]
between 2010 and now.
And you also see,
with the purple dots,
that there are many
times that are now
enriched that didn't
used to be enriched,
if you use the
2010 [? go ?] data.
So it's very important
to know which version
of the two [INAUDIBLE] of
the data that you're using.
And so here is just
a few [AUDIO OUT]
best practices for
bioinformatics experiments
should be.
People who use curated
resources and associated tools,
should include publication
dates and version number
of their tools, so the
date of the data set
and version number
of their tools.
And also, I find
sometimes in papers,
people make
additional annotations
because they found
it was incomplete.
And so this information,
these additional annotations,
are not always publicly
available.
I would just like to
conclude by saying
that biocuration should be an
integral part of the data life
cycle.
And so right now, it's often
that the curation occurs
post publication--
but I'm really
hoping that we
can get to a point
where the biocuration will also
be part of the data management
plan, part of the collection
plan, and part of the analysis.
And that it won't just be
curated after the fact.
So I'm going to stop here.
I took a quite a bit of time.
And I would like to
thank you for being here,
and acknowledge the main
projects I'm involved with.
Jack Van Horn: Thank you very much,
Pascale, that was fantastic.
Rich talk.
We've had a number of questions.
We have a couple-- look
at a couple of the themes
of the questions, they seem to
revolve around quality control,
and how automated
quality control
and verification [AUDIO OUT].
They're also, when you're
doing a manual curation,
how do you decide which
studies to include?
And is there a panel of
experts, or some sort of expert
[AUDIO OUT]?
Can you address some
of that, perhaps?
Pascale Gaudet: Sure.
So in terms of
[AUDIO OUT], I think
it really depends on the type
of data you're looking at.
So for example, for
sequence information,
you can certainly do that
by automatically making sure
that the [AUDIO OUT]
you're annotating really
corresponds to a position in the
referenced genome, for example.
In terms of literature
curation, it's
very hard to have net
that will catch problems
that-- we certainly
have the same papers by,
for example, Christophe
[? Decimau's ?] group where
they compare the gene
ontology annotations made,
predicted electronically.
And then they compare
how often these
were confirmed by experimental
annotations later.
So that also helps to do some
what we call sanity checks.
It's true that the quality
controls are very important.
Jack Van Horn: One of the other
questions were--
are many of the databases
that you mentioned,
are they publicly available?
Pascale Gaudet: Yeah, they should all be.
Jack Van Horn: Fantastic.
One question I had is, you
mentioned [AUDIO OUT] people
who are biocurators.
And I'm curious what
sort of involvement
you see from people from
the library sciences,
or almost like museum
sciences, who've
had some experience with this?
And are you seeing some
sort of comparisons
between the type of work being
done in libraries and museums,
with the type of work that's
being done with biocuration?
Pascale Gaudet: Yeah, it's funny because I was reading articles about this
recently, and my
experience-- and it's
consistent with what
I was reading-- is
it's not sufficient.
It's true that
[AUDIO OUT] sciences,
we started to develop tools and
infrastructure independently,
really with the life
sciences in mind.
But definitely,
we can [AUDIO OUT]
[? college ?] that library
and scientists have
accumulated over the years.
So This is also
another direction
that this community should
take, in my opinion.
Jack Van Horn: Yeah, I mean, it seems
like-- and somebody had asked
a question about [AUDIO OUT]
fundamental difference
between [AUDIO OUT] archivist
[AUDIO OUT] stockpiling
examples of data, versus
curating that data-- which
is sort of an ongoing process of
continuing to go back and make
sure that it's accurate and
up to date, ans as you say,
versioned or dated, so that
people know how to use it.
Would you mind commenting
just a little bit
about that distinction, and
why that's so important?
Pascale Gaudet: About why-- yeah, the
accumulation versus the-- yeah.
Well, I think this is
where-- the idea is we need
to know what we know right now.
I think this is
extremely important.
And this is also as
much-- as hopeful
as I am in terms of
the automated methods--
that the automated
text mining can
go through all the
literature, and all the data
sets, and find relations.
But they will not
be able to find
what has been proven [AUDIO OUT]
which we currently know
[AUDIO OUT].
It's really a [INAUDIBLE],
especially more [AUDIO OUT].
Knowing what we know.
And it's a very--
a very high goal,
but it's very important,
in my opinion,
in order to be able
to progress further.
There was a paper that
dates from a few years,
by John [? Yuan, ?] that says,
"why most published research
findings are false."
And that's probably
an exaggeration,
but there's certainly a lot
of hype in the literature,
and a lot of things
that never get
produced once they're
published once.
So it's great, but
if you [AUDIO OUT]
have a real current
state of knowledge base,
I think it's very difficult for
us, as a research community,
to make progress in making
new, relevant discoveries.
Jack Van Horn: Well, I think and
on that comment,
this is a great
place to conclude
our lecture from this morning.
I'd like to thank Pascale
Gaudet, once again,
for a very interesting lecture.
And I want to encourage you
all to tune in again next week,
on this same channel, same time,
to hear the next in our series.
Again, we're very excited
to be bringing this to you.
Please let others know.
We're very excited to
have a rich audience,
and are very excited
to be doing this.
Again, all the
videos will be shown
on the BD2K Training
Coordinating Center website
here within moments
after the lecture.
So Dr. Gaudet, [AUDIO OUT]
willing, and will
make those available, as well.
Anyway, once again, [AUDIO OUT]
and enjoy your weekend.
Pascale Gaudet: Thank you.
Jack Van Horn: Thank you again, Pascale.